Here's the story the way we usually like it. There's this guy, and he's back behind enemy lines. Maybe he's dropped there in the middle of the night. Maybe he sneaks in under the border. Whatever, he's there. He's been there for a while, months, years maybe. He's in disguise, operating on our behalf. No one suspects. No one can tell. He looks and acts just like them.
这就是我们通常喜欢的那种故事。有一个人，他回到了敌后。也许他是半夜被空投在那里的，也许他是溜过边境潜入的。总之，他在那里。他在那里待了一段时间，几个月，也许几年。他乔装打扮，为我们效力。没有人怀疑，也没有人能看出来。他的外表和行为举止和他们一模一样。
And then, they're in their midst for so long, speaking their language, eating their food, breathing their air, watching their TV shows and reading their newspapers, something happens to him. He starts to change. He starts to become more like them.
他在他们中间待得太久了，说着他们的语言，吃着他们的食物，呼吸着他们的空气，看着他们的电视节目，读着他们的报纸，于是，他身上发生了一些变化。他开始变得越来越像他们。
And then, when it's time for him to strike, to launch his mission against them, he hesitates. He's not sure who he sympathizes with anymore. It's a very romantic idea, this idea of what it means to live inside the enemy's camp. But sometimes this is the way it really happens.
然后，当他该出击、对他们执行任务时，他犹豫了。他不再确定自己同情的是哪一边。这种生活在敌营中的想法是一个非常浪漫的念头，但有时这正是现实中发生的情况。
Today on our radio program we have that story happening to several different people in several different places in several different ways. True stories from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. Each week on our program we choose some subject, bring you documentaries, interviews, short fiction, found tape, found writing, anything we can think of on that subject.
今天我们的广播节目里，就有这样几个不同的人，在不同地方，以不同方式上演着这样的故事。来自芝加哥WBEZ的真实故事，这就是由公共广播国际（Public Radio International）发行的《美国生活》（This American Life）。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来纪录片、采访、短篇小说、发现的录音、发现的文字，任何我们能想到的关于该主题的内容。
I'm Ira Glass, today on our program, Life Behind Enemy Lines, our show in four acts.
我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），今天我们的节目主题是“敌后生活”，我们的节目分为四幕。
Act One, Confession. In that act, the true story of a fixer for the Catholic Church and how he came to sympathize with the people that he was sent to deceive.
第一幕，“忏悔”。这一幕讲述了一个天主教会中间人的真实故事，讲述了他如何开始同情那些他被派去欺骗的人们。
Act Two, Blood Agent, how microscopic beings inside you and me can control our thoughts and minds, no kidding.
第二幕，“血液特工”，讲述了你我体内的微小生物如何控制我们的思想和心灵，这不是开玩笑。
Act Three, Sleeping With Your Enemy, in which we ask the question, whose side is your girlfriend on? Whose?
第三幕，“与你的敌人同眠”，在这一幕中，我们提出了这样一个问题：你的女朋友站在哪一边？哪一边？
And Act Four, Yet Another Ineffective Road Map For World Leadership. In that act, two political enemies try to hang out on each other's turf, get closer to each other, try to become friends. What happens? Stay with us.
第四幕，“又一个无效的世界领导力路线图”。在这一幕中，两个政治敌人试图在对方的地盘上相处，拉近彼此的距离，努力成为朋友。结果如何？请继续收听。
Act One, Confession. This is the story of a young priest who is sent out on a series jobs by church administrators to squelch some problems. And spending time out among the people, he finds it harder and harder to keep doing his job. Carl Marziali tells the tale from Los Angeles.
第一幕，“忏悔”。这是一个年轻神父的故事，他被教会行政人员派去执行一系列任务，以平息一些问题。而在人群中待了一段时间后，他发现自己越来越难以继续这份工作了。卡尔·马尔齐亚利（Carl Marziali）在洛杉矶讲述了这个故事。
Patrick Wall was just really wanted to be at 26. He was a monk studying theology at St. John's Monastery in rural Minnesota. He lived in a quiet room facing the lake. He looked forward to a life of study and prayer. It was late summer, 1991.
帕特里克·沃尔（Patrick Wall）26岁时，只想当个修士。他在明尼苏达州农村的圣约翰修道院学习神学。他住在一个面对湖泊的安静房间里。他期待着一种学习和祈祷的生活。那是1991年的夏末。
The first day that school started out, pretty uneventful, went to morning prayer at seven o'clock like normal. Went down for breakfast like normal. Went back up to my room. Was literally brushing my teeth when there was a knock on my door, which is extremely out of the ordinary. And it was Abbot Jerome Tyson.
开学的第一天，很平静，七点钟像往常一样去晨祷。像往常一样下去吃早餐。回到我的房间。我正在刷牙时，有人敲我的门，这非常不寻常。那是杰罗姆·泰森（Jerome Tyson）院长。
Well the Abbot is a very quiet guy, and he usually never went up on that floor of the monastery. So he says, "May I come in." "Yes, Father Abbot, no problem." So he comes in, sits down, and I've got my books out. I've got class in ten minutes. What's up? And he said, "Well, Father Dan Ward has told me that you would be a good person for this particular job. And we have a situation over in St. Mary's hall that we need to be a faculty resident."
院长是个非常安静的人，他通常从不去修道院的那一层。所以他说：“我可以进来吗？”“当然可以，泰森院长，没问题。”于是他进来坐下，我的书都摊开着。我十分钟后有课。怎么了？他说：“丹·沃德（Dan Ward）神父告诉我，你是做这项工作的合适人选。我们在圣玛丽大厅有一个职位，我们需要一个教职员工。”
The faculty resident is the live-in counsellor at the college dorm. The campus at St. John's includes a university.
教职员工是大学宿舍的住校辅导员。圣约翰的校园里有一所大学。
I said "Well I'd love to be a faculty resident someday. I think that's a great idea." And he said, "No, today." And when I asked Abbot Jerome specifically what it was for, what was going on, he said, "Well, I can't tell you that."
我说：“我将来很乐意担任教职员工。我觉得这是个好主意。”他说：“不是将来，是今天。”当我问杰罗姆院长具体是做什么的，发生了什么事时，他说：“嗯，我不能告诉你。”
We had numerous sexual abuse cases that had been popping up. So ultimately there's only one conclusion that can be drawn, that there was an allegation that they must have thought somewhat credible or probable. And they needed to pull that particular monk and off I went.
当时我们出现了许多性虐待案件。所以最终只能得出一个结论，即他们一定认为某项指控是可信或可能的。他们需要撤掉那个特定的修士，于是我就去了。
That afternoon, Wall moved his stuff out of his room and into the freshman dorm. His instructions were simple, put the kids at ease and don't say anything about the monk you're replacing. He organized a pizza party for the students. He told them he was taking over as faculty resident but that he couldn't say why. There were no questions. Wall didn't know it then, but he was being tested. Unfortunately for him, he passed.
那天下午，沃尔把他的东西从房间搬到了新生宿舍。他的指示很简单：让孩子们放松，不要提你取代的那个修士。他为学生们组织了一个披萨派对。他告诉他们，他接手了教职员工的工作，但不能说明原因。没有人问什么。沃尔当时并不知道，他正在接受考验。不幸的是，他通过了。
His dream was to be a monk as he understood monks to be, devout and learned men who live in monasteries. By showing a knack for damage control, he put himself on a less spiritual path. Before long, the Abbot appointed him to a sexual abuse response team and sent him to the church of St. Elizabeth's in the town of Hastings. He was replacing a pastor who had been withdrawn for what the monastery called "a credible allegation." Wall arrived at St. Elizabeth's on February 2, 1993.
他的梦想是成为他所理解的那种修士，即虔诚、博学、住在修道院里的人。通过展示出处理危机的天赋，他走上了一条不再那么纯粹的属灵道路。不久，院长任命他加入一个性虐待应对小组，并将他派往黑斯廷斯镇的圣伊丽莎白教堂。他接替了一位因教会所谓的“可信指控”而被撤职的牧师。沃尔于1993年2月2日到达圣伊丽莎白教堂。
Replacing a pastor is not easy. People in a parish tend to get attached to their priest. Replacing a disgraced pastor is harder. A lot of people believe their priest can do no wrong, and they are not shy about telling his replacement.
接替牧师并不容易。教区居民往往会对他们的神父产生依恋。接替一位名誉扫地的牧师更难。许多人认为他们的神父不可能做错事，而且他们毫不避讳地告诉他的继任者。
They were very forward and forthright and angry. And they said, "You know Father, I'm really sad that you're here. I'm really sorry that you had to come because we really liked the other monk. And we don't think he should have been removed." And that was it.
他们非常直接、坦率且愤怒。他们说：“你知道吗，神父，你在这里让我感到很难过。我很遗憾你不得不来，因为我们真的很喜欢那位修士。我们认为他不应该被撤职。”就是这样。
And then I said, "I'm really sorry that that particular monk had to be removed, and I'm here because my abbot asked me to be here." I tried to be as candid and simple as possible, but I felt taken back. And I felt sad from the very beginning. And I didn't enjoy that experience.
然后我说：“我很遗憾那位修士不得不被撤职，我在这里是因为院长要求我在这里。”我尽量表现得坦诚简单，但我感到很受挫。从一开始我就感到很难过。我不喜欢那段经历。
At first, Wall tried to raise morale. He told parishioners what he himself had been told, that the alleged abuse took place, a., some time ago, and b., somewhere else. But it wasn't long before victims at St. Elizabeth's began coming forward. They would show up unannounced at the rectory, or in the church after mass, and ask to speak to him in private. Then they would start with a tiny revelation.
起初，沃尔试图提振士气。他告诉教区居民他自己被告知的情况，即所谓的虐待发生在：甲，很久以前；乙，在其他地方。但没过多久，圣伊丽莎白教堂的受害者就开始站出来了。他们会不请自来地出现在牧师住宅，或者弥撒后的教堂里，请求私下与他谈话。然后，他们会从一个小小的揭露开始。
It's unforgettable. It's absolutely unforgettable when they start to tell you. And they only tell you very small, cryptic little things. There are code words for everything. And they broach the subject to see what you're going to do with it and to see if you're going to actually believe them. And obviously I'm 27 years old. I'm not exactly sure what to do with it emotionally. I really had no idea what to do with it.
那是令人难忘的。当他们开始告诉你时，绝对是令人难忘的。他们只告诉你非常微小、晦涩的事情。一切都有代号。他们提出这个话题，看看你会怎么处理，看看你是否真的相信他们。显然我当时才27岁。我在情感上确实不知道该怎么办。我真的不知道该怎么办。
So how did you deal with it when the victim or victims came forward and told you about what had happened? Do you try to comfort them? Do you try to tell them that-- I mean what do you do? Do you try to restore their faith in the church? Or do you just listen and write up a complaint and send it on?
那么，当受害者站出来告诉你发生了什么事时，你是如何处理的？你会试着安慰他们吗？你会试着告诉他们——我的意思是，你做了什么？你是否试着恢复他们对教会的信心？还是你只是听着，写一份投诉，然后发上去？
You don't even write up a complaint. Basically you get a few of the facts, and then you pass that on to the diocese. And honestly, unfortunately it's easy to deal with because these people never go to church again because they really view that person as representing God. So it's hard for them to publicly ever celebrate or to practice their faith again. So they just disappear honestly.
你甚至不用写投诉。基本上你获取一些事实，然后将其转交给教区。老实说，不幸的是，处理这些事情很容易，因为这些人再也不会去教堂了，因为他们真正把那个人视为上帝的代表。所以他们很难公开庆祝或再次实践他们的信仰。所以老实说，他们就消失了。
Did you ever wonder whether you should make a special effort when they came to you, beyond the effort that you might make to convince somebody else to come back to the Church? To do something more for these victims or to offer them counseling or something to try to make up for what had happened?
当他们来找你时，你有没有想过你应该做出特别的努力，而不是仅仅为了说服别人回到教会而做的那种努力？为这些受害者做更多的事情，或者提供咨询，或者做些什么来弥补已经发生的事情？
It's a difficult situation because you really need to remain neutral. And your natural inclination, especially as priests, is to be sympathetic and to heal. But there's no way that you're going to be allowed to be part of the healing process because ultimately you're part of the defendant. You are the institution that brought about the hurt. And so you really have to put your professional hat on and keep an arm's distance.
这是一个困难的情况，因为你确实需要保持中立。而你的自然倾向，尤其是作为神父，是去同情和治愈。但是你根本不可能被允许参与治愈过程，因为归根结底你是被告的一部分。你是造成伤害的那个机构。所以你真的必须戴上职业的面具，保持距离。
Wall survived the scandal at St. Elizabeth's, and he helped a superior survive it too. He never told parishioners about the allegations in their parish, and the stories he was hearing in private never became public.
沃尔在圣伊丽莎白教堂的丑闻中幸存了下来，他还帮助一位上级也幸存了下来。他从未告诉教区居民关于他们教区内指控的事情，他在私下里听到的故事也从未公开。
After serving a year at St. Elizabeth's, Wall thought he would come back to the monastery. But near the end of his term, he received a letter from the Abbot instructed him to report to another parish, St. Bernard's. The monk there had been having an affair and paying for it with church money. This was not the assignment Wall had in mind, but part of him was flattered.
在圣伊丽莎白教堂服务一年后，沃尔以为他会回到修道院。但在任期结束前，他收到院长的一封信，指示他去另一个教区——圣伯纳德教堂报到。那里的修士一直在搞婚外情，并用教会的钱来维持。这不是沃尔想要的分配，但从某种程度上说，他感到受宠若惊。
I felt pretty good about it because all of a sudden, I'm 28 years old and I'm an administrator of a parish. I'm being turned loose as the boss. That's a compliment as far as I'm concerned. And I really felt I was doing the right thing.
我当时感觉还不错，因为突然间，我28岁了，我成了教区的管理员。我被放出来当老板了。就我而言，这是一种恭维。我真的觉得我做的是正确的事。
Not long after Wall arrived at St. Bernard's, an agent from the IRS knocked on his door. The agent presented a bill, payable immediately, for $600,000 in back taxes, interest and penalties for undeclared profits from a church-run lottery. The business manager was not available to answer questions because he had been the other person in the affair and had been removed along with the monk. Wall had to take a crash course in bookkeeping to pay the IRS.
沃尔到达圣伯纳德教堂后不久，一位国税局（IRS）的特工敲了他的门。特工出示了一张账单，要求立即支付60万美元的欠税、利息和罚款，原因是教会经营的彩票未申报利润。业务经理无法回答问题，因为他就是那段婚外情的另一方，和那位修士一起被撤职了。沃尔不得不进行会计速成班，以支付国税局。
The rest of his time at St. Bernard's, Wall did what every priest does. He celebrated mass, performed weddings and funerals, baptized babies. And he heard confessions, including those of other priests. Despite the headlines, the percentage of priests who have abused minors is relatively low. Celibacy is another story. In a recent Los Angeles Times poll, only one third of priests said they do not waver from the celibate life. After a while, Wall stopped thinking of broken vows as something foreign to his world.
在圣伯纳德教堂剩下的时间里，沃尔做了每个神父都会做的事。他主持弥撒，举行婚礼和葬礼，为婴儿洗礼。他倾听忏悔，包括其他神父的忏悔。尽管有头条新闻，但虐待未成年人的神父比例相对较低。独身则是另一回事。在最近《洛杉矶时报》的一项民意调查中，只有三分之一的神父表示他们从未动摇过独身生活。过了一段时间，沃尔不再认为违背誓言是他世界以外的事情。
Once you see enough people fall, and once you hear enough confessions of different priests, you look at yourself in the mirror and you say, am I really any different? And the chances of me maintaining a celibate way of life without failure along the way are so low that ultimately, either I have to change or the system needs to change.
当你看到足够多的人堕落，当你听到足够多不同神父的忏悔，你看着镜子里的自己，你会说：我真的有什么不同吗？我维持独身生活而不中途失败的几率太低了，最终，要么我必须改变，要么这个系统需要改变。
What about-- there must be lot of priests who believe in being priests and have decided that the rule of celibacy is nonsense, and so are willing to lead a double life of sorts. Was that something that you considered?
那——一定有很多神父相信身为神父的意义，却认为独身规则是胡说八道，所以愿意过一种双重生活。那是你考虑过的事情吗？
No, that's really not my personality. I'm a terrible liar. I turn red. I'm just really bad. And I had seen priests who maintained heterosexual relationships with women. And I saw the effects of it because it's a life of contradiction. Because the relationship is there, it's exclusive, but you can't profess it and everyone around you knows what's going on. And that's not happiness. That's not a true coming together. I just couldn't see myself doing that. That's just not me.
不，那真的不是我的个性。我是个糟糕的骗子。我会脸红。我真的很差劲。我见过那些与女性维持异性恋关系的神父。我看到了它的后果，因为这是一种充满矛盾的生活。因为关系在那里，它是排他的，但你不能公开它，而你周围的每个人都知道发生了什么。那不是幸福。那不是真正的结合。我只是无法想象自己那样做。那不是我。
After St. Bernard's, the assignments kept coming. The next one was an affair between a priest and a nun. After that, a new parish where a teacher had abused a student and the priest was living with his housekeeper. Four years, four parishes, four scandals. There are good, dedicated priests out there, but they're not the ones who get replaced. By the very nature of his job, Wall was acquiring a skewed and depressing view of the priesthood.
在圣伯纳德教堂之后，任务不断。下一个是一段神父与修女的恋情。在那之后，是一个新的教区，那里的老师虐待了学生，而神父与他的管家住在一起。四年，四个教区，四起丑闻。外面有好的、敬业的神父，但他们不是被撤换的那种。由于他工作的本质，沃尔对神职人员的看法变得扭曲且令人沮丧。
Did you ever ask not to be given those assignments?
你有没有要求不要被分配那些任务？
Yeah, I did. And I specifically asked to be able to come back to the prep school and teach. But the needs of the monastery were so great at that point that again, it was only going to be another year. I was only going to have to go to St. Bernard's for another year. So it sounds like a bad construction deal, two more weeks. Give me two more weeks and we'll be done. And it just kept going on. It kept going on.
是的，我要求过。我特别要求回到预科学校教书。但当时修道院的需求太大了，所以同样，那只是多一年而已。我只需要再去圣伯纳德教堂一年。这听起来像个糟糕的建筑合同，“再两周，再给我两周我们就完成了。”但它一直在继续。它一直在继续。
Meanwhile, the monks he replaced were getting exactly what Wall himself had asked for. They were going back to the monastery, permanently.
与此同时，他所取代的那些修士得到了沃尔自己所要求的东西。他们回到了修道院，永久性地。
I'd run across them at community meetings and whenever we had chapter votes and all that. And it's hard not to be judgmental. The other thing I found hard was that my whole career path was driven by other people's mistakes. And that's the last thing I ever expected in monastic life. I really expected to work in a parish for a year, to go off to grad school, come back, teach, coach football at the university. And to live a pretty darn good life, a balance between prayer, and teaching, and working as a teacher. So they changed my career path. They changed my whole trajectory in life.
我在社区会议上，每当我们有支部投票时，我都会碰到他们。不加评判是很难的。我发现难的另一件事是，我整个的职业道路都是由别人的错误所驱动的。这是我在修道院生活中最没想到的事情。我真的期望在教区工作一年，去读研究生，回来，教书，在大学教橄榄球。过一种相当不错的生活，在祈祷、教书和工作之间保持平衡。所以他们改变了我的职业道路。他们改变了我整个人生轨迹。
Without fully realizing it, Wall had been initiated into a brotherhood of priests known informally as fixers or cleaners. They replace problem priests, they hide things in the archives, they reassure the faithful. In short, they make it all go away. Visually, he was perfect for the job. He was barrel-chested, a former offensive lineman on the St. John's football team. He was young, friendly. He was the anti-stereotype of a troubled monk. The Abbott couldn't have found a better prospect if he had picked a model out of a catalog. But Wall did more than just PR. He became familiar with the law of the church called canon law, specifically with the different archives canon law sets up for storing and hiding information.
沃尔在没有完全意识到的情况下，被引入了一个非正式地被称为“修理工”或“清洁工”的修士兄弟会。他们取代有问题的神父，把事情藏在档案里，安抚信徒。简而言之，他们让一切消失。从外表上看，他非常适合这份工作。他胸膛宽阔，是圣约翰橄榄球队的前进攻前锋。他年轻、友好。他是问题修士的“反刻板印象”。如果院长从目录里挑选一个模特，他也不可能找到更好的候选人了。但沃尔做的不仅仅是公关。他开始熟悉教会法，特别是教会法为存储和隐藏信息而设立的不同档案。
First is a historical archives, which is just a names, dates, people, those kinds of things. Then you have the secret archives.
首先是历史档案，那只是一些名字、日期、人物之类的事情。然后你有秘密档案。
The secret archives, is that literally what they're called, the secret archives? I mean why were they set up?
秘密档案，那是它们的字面名称吗，秘密档案？我的意思是它们为什么要设立？
They're set up for the protection of individuals. So that the bishop has the responsibility to take things that would be consider scandalous, things that might hurt individuals' reputations, and to be able to place them there so they wouldn't easily be exposed.
它们是为了保护个人而设立的。这样主教就有责任把那些会被认为是丑闻的、可能会损害个人名誉的事情，放置在那里，以免轻易曝光。
OK, when you call it the secret archives though, it makes it sound sinister. It makes it sound like it's there for the protection, to really protect the Church. I'm not saying that's what it is, but that's how it sounds. I mean what really is the purpose of these so called secrets? Why can't everything be in the personnel records and then some items just be labeled "Confidential" or whatever.
好的，当你称其为秘密档案时，它听起来很阴险。它听起来好像是为了保护，真的保护教会。我并不是说这就是它的本质，但听起来就是这样。我的意思是这些所谓的秘密的真正目的是什么？为什么不能把所有东西都放在人事记录里，然后把某些项目贴上“机密”或类似标签？
Well you have to do give Rome credit. I mean they have wonderful procedure. These are things that have worked out for centuries. And that has always been the secret to one of the defenses of the Church. If you don't know what you're asking for, they don't have to produce it.
嗯，你得给罗马记上一功。我的意思是他们有很棒的程序。这些都是几个世纪以来行之有效的事情。这一直是教会辩护的秘密之一。如果你不知道你在要求什么，他们就不必提供它。
Did you ever-- when you were working for the Church, cleaning up these situations of abuse and having to tell parishioners some of the facts but not all of the facts about what was going on-- did you ever feel complicit in the cover up of all of this?
当你为教会工作时，处理这些虐待情况，不得不告诉教区居民部分而不是全部的事实，你是否曾经感到自己是这一切掩盖行为的共犯？
I have some regrets, but I think I did it in good faith because, as I was taught and as I believe, that was my role, to help the Church in the long run and to be obedient to what I was asked to do. And it's only later on that, as I had greater experience, I couldn't support it any longer. And I felt that if I was going to stay, I was going to not only support it, but I was going to get deeper into it. I was going to be asked to do other assignments to follow pedophiles. I was going to be asked to be on the finance council to try to figure out ways to mitigate the huge financial cost of childhood sexual abuse by priests and the religious.
我有一些遗憾，但我认为我是在真诚地做这些事，因为正如我所学到的和我所相信的那样，那是我的角色，从长远来看帮助教会，并服从我被要求做的事情。只是后来，随着经验的增加，我再也无法支持它了。我觉得如果我留下来，我不只会支持它，还会陷得更深。我会被要求执行其他任务去跟踪恋童癖者。我会被要求进入财务委员会，试图想办法减轻神职人员虐待儿童带来的巨大经济代价。
And I remember having an epiphany and sitting on the porch at St. Mary's in Stillwater. And that's when I came to the conclusion that this is pretty much going to be my career path. I'd be there for another year or two as the administrator. And then I would go on to another assignment. And I just couldn't do it any longer.
我记得在斯蒂尔沃特的圣玛丽门廊上顿悟的时候。那时我得出结论，这就是我未来的职业道路了。作为管理员，我会在那里再待一两年。然后我会去执行另一个任务。我只是再也做不下去了。
After four years of deceiving the faithful about the extent of priestly misconduct, of protecting the institution over the health and welfare of the victims, of covering for the perpetrators and letting the problem fester, Patrick Wall decided he was on the wrong side. On July 31, 1998, Wall quit the priesthood. He was 33 years old.
经过四年欺骗信徒关于神职人员不当行为的程度、为了机构利益而牺牲受害者健康和福祉、为作恶者掩盖并任由问题恶化，帕特里克·沃尔决定他站在了错误的一边。1998年7月31日，沃尔退出了神职。他当时33岁。
Leaving was difficult. If you want to leave honorably, you need permission, which doesn't come easily or quickly. It took more than a year in Wall's case. Then, once you're out, there are practical challenges, like trying to get a job with a Master of Theology on your resume. In the end, it was his experience as a fixer that translated best to the real world. Wall read an Op-Ed in the LA Times by John Manly, an attorney who sues the Church on behalf of sexual abuse victims.
离开是很困难的。如果你想光荣地离开，你需要许可，这并不容易或迅速。在沃尔的例子里，这花了超过一年时间。然后，一旦你离开了，就有实际的挑战，比如试着在简历上有个神学硕士的情况下找工作。最后，是他作为“修理工”的经验最能转化为现实世界。沃尔在《洛杉矶时报》上读到了约翰·曼利（John Manly）的一篇评论文章，这位律师代表性虐待受害者起诉教会。
He essentially separated himself amongst all the different attorneys in saying that we need to protect the sheep and not the shepherd. It's not the problem of the victims. It's not the problem of the particular perpetrators per se or some particular issue like homosexuality or whatever. The problem is within the institution itself.
他本质上在所有不同的律师中将自己区分开来，说我们需要保护羊群，而不是牧羊人。这不是受害者的问题。这本身不是特定作恶者的问题，也不是同性恋或任何特定问题。问题存在于机构本身。
By this point, Wall was convinced that lawsuits were the only way to reform the Church. He called Manly and offered to help. Soon they were on the phone constantly. Wall took him step by step through Church bureaucracy. Manly was amazed.
到了这一点，沃尔坚信诉讼是改革教会的唯一途径。他打电话给曼利，主动提供帮助。很快他们就在电话里没完没了地交流。沃尔一步步带着他了解教会官僚机构。曼利感到非常惊讶。
John didn't know all the different documents that are out there. And then John would be working on things, and he'd call me up and say, "Dude, what do I do with this? What does this mean? What am I supposed to do with it? What are other things? Where else can I look?" And I remember I think he was quite surprised when I showed him the penal code of canon law and exactly what we need to ask for. He just couldn't believe that it was there, that they would have that level of sophistication.
约翰不知道外面有所有那些不同的文件。然后约翰会在处理事情，他会打电话给我说：“老兄，我该怎么处理这个？这是什么意思？我该用它做什么？还有别的东西吗？我还能从哪里找？”我记得当他向他展示教会法刑法典以及我们具体需要要求什么时，他相当惊讶。他简直不敢相信它竟然就在那里，他们竟然有那种程度的复杂性。
Wall started working for Manly's law firm full time in October of 2002. Using his knowledge of Latin and Italian, he translates and interprets Church records. He helps the firm identify and request key documents like psychological assessments of priests from the secret archives. The fact that he switched sides, that he's fighting the Church, doesn't seem to trouble him. He believes he's doing what God wants him to do, which is what he's always believed.
沃尔于2002年10月开始全职为曼利的律师事务所工作。利用他的拉丁语和意大利语知识，他翻译和解释教会记录。他帮助事务所识别和请求关键文件，如从秘密档案中获取神职人员的心理评估报告。他倒戈、他对抗教会的事实，似乎并没有困扰他。他相信他在做上帝希望他做的事，这也是他一直以来所相信的。
There's another part to Wall's job at the firm, which doesn't have anything to do with case law. Last week, he stayed on the phone with a man for an hour and a half, listening to him talk about the priest who abused him and who might still be hurting other people. Wall finds himself talking to victims about all kinds of things, everything he was not allowed to talk about before back when he was a priest.
沃尔在事务所的工作还有另一部分，与判例法无关。上周，他和一个男人在电话里聊了一个半小时，听他讲述虐待他的神父，而那个神父可能还在伤害其他人。沃尔发现自己和受害者谈论各种各样的事情，他在作为神父时被禁止谈论的一切。
I feel I really do pastoral work when I'm working with victims every day on every single issue.
我觉得当我每天与受害者就每一个问题进行合作时，我才真正地在做牧灵工作。
Before you were part of a holy order, and now you're working with a bunch of lawyers. And it's hard to know these days where priests belong on the ethical ladder, but most people know exactly where to put lawyers. And so it's just odd to hear you talk about this work being more fulfilling in some ways than what you were doing before.
以前你属于一个神圣的组织，现在你和一群律师一起工作。如今很难知道神父在道德阶梯上属于什么位置，但大多数人确切地知道把律师放在哪里。所以听到你说这份工作在某些方面比你以前做的工作更充实，真是太奇怪了。
Well we're dealing with people at the lowest ebb of where they're at. They're dealing with the greatest pain they've ever experienced. And one of the greatest things that we find is that they can no longer participate in the sacramental life of the Church because of the seven sacraments, the one thing that's really clear is that it takes a priest to administer the sacrament. And every sacrament is either through touching or it's through breath, through words. It's in close proximity to the priest. And that is the symbol of their abuse. So we're dealing with some of the most damaged people within the church, and it is a very fulfilling ministry, I find, in being pastoral to be with them. Because honestly, we're one of the few symbols of hope that they have. Patrick
嗯，我们是在处理处于人生最低谷的人。他们正在处理他们经历过的最大的痛苦。我们发现最重要的事情之一是，由于七件圣事，真正明确的一点是，需要神父来执行圣事，因此他们再也无法参与教会的圣礼生活了。每一项圣事要么通过触摸，要么通过呼吸，通过话语。它与神父的距离很近。而那就是他们被虐待的象征。所以我们是在处理教会内部一些最受伤害的人，我发现，通过与他们在一起进行牧灵工作是非常充实的。因为老实说，我们是他们拥有的为数不多的希望象征之一。帕特里克。
Wall is married now. He and his wife have a two year old daughter, who they plan to send to Catholic school. They all go to mass every Sunday.
沃尔现在结婚了。他和妻子有一个两岁的女儿，他们计划送她去天主教学校。他们每个周日都去弥撒。
Carl Marziali attends mass with his family in Los Angeles. Coming up, Enemies On Our Turf, controlling the minds of ants, or rats, and of you and me. This is not some whacked out conspiracy theory my friend, this is science. Proof in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
卡尔·马尔齐亚利在洛杉矶与家人一起参加弥撒。接下来，“我们地盘上的敌人”，控制蚂蚁、老鼠，还有你我的思想。这不是什么疯狂的阴谋论，我的朋友，这是科学。一分钟后证明，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际，我们的节目继续。
[MUSIC - "HUNU" BY DEERHOOF]
[音乐 - DEERHOOF的"HUNU"]
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring your a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Enemy Camp, stories of what it means to work behind enemy lines. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Blood Agent.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，“敌营”，关于在敌后工作意味着什么的故事。我们已经到达节目的第二幕。第二幕，“血液特工”。
Nature, it turns out, is full of enemy agents, living behind enemy lines, doing their work. Parasites, they're literally parasites. Carl Zimmer has written a book about the different strategies that these parasites use to survive. And it makes for weirdly compelling reading. For one thing, who knew how prevalent they were?
事实证明，大自然中充满了敌人特工，生活在敌后，进行着他们的工作。寄生虫，它们确实是寄生虫。卡尔·齐默（Carl Zimmer）写了一本关于这些寄生虫用来生存的不同策略的书。这读起来有着诡异的吸引力。一方面，谁知道它们如此普遍？
Most creatures on Earth are living inside an enemy. And they are trying to fight that enemy, trying to survive, trying to outwit.
地球上的大多数生物都生活在敌人的体内。它们正在试图与那个敌人战斗，试图生存，试图智取。
Just to give people a sense of the range of things that different parasites do, could you tell the story of the parasite that gets into ants, the lancet fluke?
为了让人们了解不同寄生虫的作用范围，你能讲讲进入蚂蚁体内的寄生虫——双盘吸虫的故事吗？
Sure, well the lancet fluke is a kind of flat worm. It starts out as an egg on the ground. And a snail comes along and eats the egg. And it irritates the snail system so eventually it coughs it up. And so there you have this clump of snail goo with a parasite in it. And while it's disgusting to us, to an ant there's nothing more delicious than snail goo. So the ant comes along, and it eats the snail goo and the parasite along with it.
当然，双盘吸虫是一种扁形虫。它最初是地面上的一枚卵。蜗牛过来吃掉了这枚卵。它刺激了蜗牛的系统，所以最终蜗牛把它咳了出来。于是你得到了一团带有寄生虫的蜗牛粘液。虽然这对我们来说很恶心，但对蚂蚁来说，没有什么比蜗牛粘液更美味的了。所以蚂蚁过来，吃掉了蜗牛粘液以及其中的寄生虫。
So now you have these flukes inside the ant. And once they recognize that they're inside the ant, they start doing some strange things. Sort of as the sun is starting to go down while the other ants are probably heading back to the nest, it gets this uncontrollable urge to climb upward. It wants to climb up. And what it generally does is it climbs up a blade of grass.
现在这些吸虫在蚂蚁体内了。一旦它们意识到自己在蚂蚁体内，它们就开始做一些奇怪的事情。大约在太阳开始下山的时候，当其他蚂蚁可能正在回巢时，它会产生一种不可抑制的向上攀爬的冲动。它想爬上去。它通常做的是爬上一根草叶。
And what's the advantage to the parasite for the ant to be up there?
这对寄生虫来说，让蚂蚁爬到那里有什么好处？
Well it's not too obvious at first. I mean it's not like the parasite wants to take in a better view. The thing is that there are these grazing mammals, sheep, cows. And that's one of their favorite grazing times, towards the end of the day. So the ant goes up there. Sheep comes along, chews on the grass. The ant gets eaten, chewed up, dies. But the flukes inside the ant, they can survive the digestive acids in the sheep's stomach. And actually sheep are where they like to live. They are their final host.
嗯，起初并不太明显。我的意思是寄生虫并不是想看更好的风景。关键是，有一些食草哺乳动物，绵羊、牛。这是它们最喜欢的放牧时间之一，接近一天结束的时候。所以蚂蚁爬上去了。绵羊过来，咀嚼草。蚂蚁被吃掉，被嚼碎，死掉了。但蚂蚁体内的吸虫，它们可以在绵羊胃里的消化酸中存活下来。事实上，绵羊正是它们喜欢居住的地方。它们是它们的最终宿主。
What's so amazing about that is not just the control that the parasite is having over the ant. That life cycle that you're describing is so complicated. It's having to go through three different animals over the course of its normal life cycle.
最神奇的不仅仅是寄生虫对蚂蚁的控制。你描述的那个生命周期太复杂了。它必须在正常生命周期中经过三种不同的动物。
Yeah, there are actually some parasites that go through six or seven different animals to get through their life cycle. It's mind boggling.
是的，实际上有些寄生虫要经过六七种不同的动物才能完成它们的生命周期。这真是令人难以置信。
It's really hard to talk about without ascribing an intentionally to them, which they don't have consciousness. They don't have brains in any way. It's hard for us to even understand what they're doing without putting that on them.
如果不归结于某种意图，就很难谈论它们，但它们并没有意识。它们没有任何方式的大脑。我们甚至很难理解它们在做什么，而不把那强加给它们。
Yeah I think because in a sense they are using us, or using other animals or other hosts in such an intentional way. And they seem to know so much. How does, say, a tapeworm inside a fish know that if it makes it flick and flail in a certain way that it'll be easier for a bird to see it so they can get inside that bird where it wants to be? It's amazing. And not only do they not have brains, a lot of them don't even have nerves. So it's just this sinister chemical wisdom they have.
是的，我认为因为在某种意义上，它们以这种有意的、目的明确的方式使用我们，或使用其他动物或其他宿主。它们似乎知道得太多了。比如，鱼体内的绦虫怎么知道如果它让它以某种方式摆动，鸟儿就更容易看到它，这样它们就能进入鸟体内，到达它想去的地方？太神奇了。而且它们不仅没有大脑，很多甚至没有神经。所以这只是一种它们拥有的邪恶的化学智慧。
And it seems like all the parasites break down into two different groups. There are the kinds that actually get inside a host and then kill it off in their drive to survive in there. And then there are others, which actually just live inside and are happily living inside forever. They want the host to survive. Could you just tell the example of the creature that eats the fish's tongue?
而且似乎所有的寄生虫都分为两个不同的群体。有一种进入宿主体内，然后在那里为了生存而杀死宿主。还有其他一些，实际上只是生活在里面，永远快乐地生活在里面。它们希望宿主生存。你能举个例子讲讲吃掉鱼舌头的生物吗？
Yeah, this is a particularly creepy one. The parasite in question is called an isopod, which is a kind of crustacean. It looks like a little pill bug or something but it lives in the water. And what it does is it swims into the mouth of a snapper, a fish. And when it's in there, it eats that fish's tongue. It just devours the tongue completely. But just the tongue. It stops there.
是的，这是一个特别令人毛骨悚然的例子。有关的寄生虫被称为等足类动物，是一种甲壳类动物。它看起来像一只小鼠妇或者什么东西，但它生活在水里。它的做法是游进鲷鱼——一种鱼——的嘴里。当它在里面时，它吃掉了那条鱼的舌头。它完全吞噬了舌头。但仅限于舌头。它到此为止。
But now this isopod, this parasite, does something very weird. It turns around so it's facing front. And hunkers down exactly where the tongue used to be. So if you look in one of these fish's mouths, you see this tongue that has these little eyes on the end of it. It's amazing. And what scientists think then happens is that the fish can then use the parasite as its tongue. It'll go out, catch some food, catch a fish. And will crush up the food on the back of this parasite. The fish I guess doesn't mind too much if it can still get its meal. And the fish can then get back to its life.
但现在这个等足类动物，这个寄生虫，做了一件非常奇怪的事情。它转过身来，面向前方。并在原来舌头的位置安顿下来。所以如果你往这些鱼的嘴里看，你会看到这个舌头上末端有小眼睛。太神奇了。科学家认为接下来发生的是，鱼可以把寄生虫当作它的舌头使用。它会出去，抓住一些食物，抓住一条鱼。并会在这个寄生虫的背上压碎食物。我想如果鱼还能吃上饭，它就不会太介意了。鱼然后可以回到它的生活中。
Some of these stories just are such gross out stories on a visceral level.
其中一些故事在直觉层面上真是太恶心了。
Well, it's funny because it disturbs us when we talk about that when it comes to parasites, but I mean why doesn't it disturb when we talk about a lion? We name football teams after lions. But we don't name football teams after tapeworms. You don't have the Chicago Tapeworms or something like that. We don't want to think about it. But we admire these predators. But what are these predators doing? These predators are taking advantage of these other life forms. They're just eating them from the outside I guess you could say. But I mean to my mind, it's just a lot more cool when they're on the inside trying to figure out how to how to make this work.
嗯，这很有趣，因为当我们谈论寄生虫时，它困扰着我们，但为什么当我们谈论狮子时，它不会困扰我们呢？我们以狮子命名橄榄球队。但我们不用绦虫命名橄榄球队。你不会有“芝加哥绦虫队”之类的。我们不想考虑它。但我们钦佩这些捕食者。但这些捕食者在做什么？这些捕食者在利用其他生命形式。我想你可以说它们只是从外面吃掉它们。但我认为，当它们在里面试图弄清楚如何让这种事情奏效时，这要酷得多。
You write, "parasitologists tend to fall in love with the parasites they study." Talk about one of the ones that you fell in love with.
你写道，“寄生虫学家往往会爱上他们研究的寄生虫。”谈谈你爱上的其中一个。
I was sort of amazed by blood flukes. They cause this disease called bilharzia or schistosomiasis. And you have to be careful if you were to swim in the pond, say in Tanzania, chances are there are these blood flukes swimming around. And they look like a little missile. They're whipping around through the water looking for human skin. And they plunge in. They have these little chemicals on their surface that let them burrow their way into your skin like it was butter or something. And then they will travel through the arteries. And they might go through your body like three times before they end up in the place they want to be, which is your liver.
我被血吸虫惊呆了。它们引起一种叫做血吸虫病的疾病。如果你在池塘里游泳，比如在坦桑尼亚，很有可能周围有这些血吸虫。它们看起来像一枚小导弹。它们在水中翻腾，寻找人类皮肤。然后它们潜入。它们的表面有一些小化学物质，让它们像钻进黄油一样钻进你的皮肤。然后它们会穿过动脉。它们可能会穿过你的身体大约三次，最后到达它们想去的地方，也就是你的肝脏。
And blood flukes come in males and females. And females are long and thin. And the males have a funny shape. They're like a canoe with little spikes in the trough. And once they find a mate, the female will lock in to the trough of the male. And they'll just lock in together. And once they've done that, they're ready to go. They decide, this is who I want to be with for the rest of my life in this human host. And so they are riding through your body, locked together on this journey, this romantic tunnel of love I guess.
血吸虫有雄性和雌性。雌性又长又细。雄性的形状很有趣。它们像独木舟，槽里有小刺。一旦它们找到伴侣，雌性就会锁进雄性的槽里。它们就这样锁在一起。一旦它们做到了，它们就准备出发了。它们决定，这就是我想在这个人类宿主中度过余生的人。所以它们在你的身体里穿行，锁在一起进行这段旅程，我想这大概是一条浪漫的爱之隧道。
You write that it's the most monogamous couple on Earth.
你写道这是地球上最一夫一妻制的一对。
Yeah I mean they are incredibly monogamous. These parasites aren't just faithful to each other. They are physically connected to each other for their whole life. And a scientist will sometimes try to pull them apart, see what happens. They crawl right back together again.
是的，我的意思是它们非常专一。这些寄生虫不仅对彼此忠诚。它们一生都在物理上连接在一起。科学家有时会试图把它们分开，看看会发生什么。它们会立刻爬回到一起。
Thinking about this as much as you have, do you start to see everything as being parasites?
思考了这么多，你开始把所有东西都看作寄生虫了吗？
I see a lot of things as being like parasites. Parasites are the most successful life form on Earth. And there could be as many as three parasites for every one free living species. It's hard to say. And if you're not a species that is living inside another thing, then you're a species with something living inside of you.
我把很多东西看作像寄生虫。寄生虫是地球上最成功的生命形式。每一种自由生活的物种可能有多达三种寄生虫。很难说。而且如果你不是一个生活在其他生物体内的物种，那么你就是一个体内有东西寄生的物种。
Is one side winning?
哪一方在赢？
I'd say the parasites have the upper hand because they're just doing so very well.
我会说寄生虫占上风，因为它们做得太成功了。
The parasites have the upper hand?
寄生虫占上风？
Sure, yeah, I mean they have the most species. They're getting around all these defenses. I mean there are things they do that either we don't know how they do it, or if we know how they do it, we can't reproduce it. We just stand in awe of it.
当然，是的，我的意思是它们拥有最多的物种。它们绕过了所有这些防御。我的意思是它们做的一些事情要么是我们不知道它们是怎么做到的，要么是我们知道它们怎么做到，却无法复制。我们只是对它肃然起敬。
I know but we know about them. They don't know about us. We're the ones with the brains and the thinking and the consciousness.
我知道，但我们知道它们。它们不知道我们。我们才是拥有大脑、思考和意识的人。
Well then maybe you're over-selling your brain. I mean the brain is a wonderful thing but these parasites are able to pull the strings in those brains in a lot of cases. Say for example, a rat. Rats are very smart animals. I mean they know how to learn. They know how to figure out their surroundings. But there is a parasite called toxoplasma, a single cell parasite. And they pick it up on the ground. And when it gets into them, they suddenly lose their fear of the smell of cats. Otherwise they're totally the same. Then the cat eats them. And then toxoplasma gets into its final host, which is a cat. So even though you have a brain, you're still being pushed toward your doom by this single cell parasite.
嗯，那也许你高估了你的大脑。我的意思是大脑是个奇妙的东西，但在很多情况下，这些寄生虫能够操纵那些大脑中的线索。举个例子，老鼠。老鼠是非常聪明的动物。我的意思是它们知道如何学习。它们知道如何弄清楚它们的环境。但有一种叫做弓形虫的寄生虫，一种单细胞寄生虫。它们在地上拾取它。当它进入它们体内时，它们突然失去了对猫的气味的恐惧。除此之外，它们完全一样。然后猫吃掉它们。然后弓形虫进入其最终宿主，即猫。所以即使你有一个大脑，你仍然被这个单细胞寄生虫推向你的厄运。
Mr. Zimmer, whose side are you on?
齐默先生，你站在哪一边？
I think I'm on the parasite's side when it comes to getting a bad rap. I'm their PR man.
当涉及到被误解时，我想我站在寄生虫这一边。我是它们的公关人员。
Because Mr. Zimmer, at some point we're all going to have to choose sides in this war. Speaking for the other humans, I want to say you're either with us or against us.
因为齐默先生，在某个时候我们都必须在这场战争中选择立场。代表其他人，我想说你要么与我们站在一起，要么站在我们的对立面。
Well, it's funny, I have not gotten seriously sick in my life, knock on wood. And I have actually gone to places where there are a lot of parasites around in order to report on how people are dealing with them. And I didn't get sick. I was really scared, but I didn't get sick. I didn't get malaria. I didn't get river blindness. I didn't get sleeping sickness.
嗯，这很有趣，我一生中从未生过重病，敲敲木头。我实际上去过有很多寄生虫的地方，为了报道人们是如何应对它们的。但我没有生病。我真的很害怕，但我没有生病。我没有得疟疾。我没有得河盲症。我没有得嗜睡症。
Wait a second. Are you saying this because they could sense that you are in league with them?
等一下。你这么说是因为它们能感觉到你与它们同流合污吗？
Who knows? Maybe they think I'm here to serve their purpose.
谁知道呢？也许它们认为我在这里是为了实现它们的目的。
Carl Zimmer, his book, the perfect reading material if you ever want to have a long talk with an eight year old boy, is Parasite Rex.
卡尔·齐默，他的书，如果你想和一个八岁的男孩进行长时间的交谈，这是完美的阅读材料，书名是《寄生虫雷克斯》（Parasite Rex）。
[MUSIC - "I LIVE OFF YOU" BY X-RAY SPEX]
[音乐 - X-RAY SPEX的"I LIVE OFF YOU"]
Act Three, Sleeping With Your Enemy. We have this story about what is hidden inside us, the secret agents within from writer Etgar Keret. Among other things, he says it is a story about his real life girlfriend. Actor Matt Malloy reads it for us. A warning to listeners before we begin. This story mentions the existence of sex.
第三幕，“与你的敌人同眠”。我们有一个关于隐藏在我们体内的东西的故事，来自作家埃特加·凯雷特（Etgar Keret）的内部特工。除其他事项外，他说这是一个关于他现实生活中女朋友的故事。演员马特·马洛伊（Matt Malloy）为我们朗读它。在开始之前给听众一个警告。这个故事提到了性的存在。
Surprised? Of course I was surprised. You go out with a girl, first date, second date, a restaurant here, a movie there, always just matinees. You start sleeping together. Sex is dynamite, and pretty soon there's feeling too.
惊讶吗？我当然很惊讶。你和一个女孩出去，第一次约会，第二次约会，在这里吃顿饭，在那里看场电影，总是看午场。你们开始睡觉。性是爆炸性的，很快也有了感觉。
And then one day she arrives all weepy. And you hug her and tell her to take it easy, everything's OK. She says she can't stand it anymore, she has this secret, not just a secret, something really awful, a curse, something she's been wanting to tell you the whole time but she didn't have the guts. This thing, it's been weighing down on her like a ton of bricks, and now she's got to tell you. She's simply got to.
然后有一天她哭哭啼啼地来了。你拥抱她，告诉她放轻松，一切都好。她说她再也受不了了，她有个秘密，不仅仅是个秘密，而是非常可怕的事情，一个诅咒，一件她一直想告诉你但没胆量说出口的事。这件事，就像重达一吨的砖头一样压在她身上，现在她必须告诉你。她不得不告诉你。
But she knows that as soon as she does, you'll leave her. And you'd be absolutely right too. And right after that, she starts crying all over again. "I won't leave you," you tell her. "I won't. I love you." You may look a little upset, but you're not. And even if you are, it's about her crying, not about her secret. You know by now that these secrets that always make a woman fall to pieces are usually nothing. And you hug them and say it's all right. It's OK. Or shhh, if they don't stop.
但她知道一旦她说出来，你就会离开她。而且你也会绝对正确。说完之后，她又开始哭了起来。“我不会离开你，”你告诉她。“我不会。我爱你。”你可能看起来有点不安，但你其实并不。即使你有，那也是因为她在哭，而不是因为她的秘密。你现在知道了，这些总是让女人崩溃的秘密通常没什么大不了的。你拥抱她们，说没关系。没事的。或者嘘，如果她们不停的话。
"It's something really terrible," she insists, as if she's picked up on how nonchalant you are about it even though you tried to hide it. "In the pit of your stomach it may sound terrible," you tell her, "but that's mostly because of the acoustics. As soon as you let it out, it won't seem nearly as bad. You'll see." And she almost believes it. She hesitates a minute and then asks, "What if I told you that at night I turn into a heavy, harry man with no neck, with a gold ring on his pinky? Would you still love me?"
“这是一件非常可怕的事，”她坚持说，好像她察觉到了你对此是多么漫不经心，尽管你试图隐藏它。“在你的胃底这听起来可能很可怕，”你告诉她，“但这主要是因为声学效果。一旦你把它释放出来，它就不会看起来那么糟了。你会看到的。”她几乎相信了。她犹豫了一分钟，然后问：“如果我告诉你，在晚上我会变成一个笨重、多毛、没有脖子的男人，小指上戴着金戒指呢？你还会爱我吗？”
And you tell are of course you would. What else can you say, that you wouldn't? She's simply trying to test you, to see whether you love her unconditionally. And you've always been a winner at tests. Truth is, as soon as you say it, she melts. And you screw right there in the living room. And afterwards, you lie there holding each other tight, and she cries because she's so relieved. And you cry too. Go figure.
你告诉她当然会。还能说什么呢，说你不会？她只是在考验你，看你是否无条件地爱她。而你一直是考验中的赢家。事实是，一旦你说出来，她就融化了。就在客厅里你们做了爱。事后，你们躺在那里紧紧拥抱，她哭了，因为她感到如释重负。你也哭了。去想清楚吧。
And unlike all the other times, she doesn't get up and leave. She stays there and falls asleep. You lie awake, looking at her beautiful body, at the sunset outside, at the moon appearing as if out of nowhere, at the silvery light flickering over her body, stroking the hair on her back. And within less than five minutes, you find yourself lying next to this guy. This short, fat guy.
而且不同于其他所有时候，她没有起身离开。她待在那里，睡着了。你躺着醒着，看着她美丽的身体，看着外面的日落，看着月亮好像凭空出现，看着银色的光在她身体上闪烁，抚摸她背上的毛发。在不到五分钟的时间里，你发现自己躺在这个家伙旁边。这个矮胖的家伙。
And the guy gets up and smiles at you and gets dressed awkwardly. He leaves the room and you follow him spellbound. He's in the den now. His thick fingers fiddling with the remote, zapping to the sports channels, championship football. When they miss a pass, he curses the TV. When they score, he gets up and does this little victory dance. After the game, he tells you that his throat is dry and his stomach is growling. He could really use a beer and a nice hunk of meat. Well done if possible with lots of onion rings. But he'd settle for some pork chops too.
那家伙起身对你微笑，笨拙地穿上衣服。他离开房间，你被迷住了，跟着他。他现在在书房里。他那粗壮的手指摆弄着遥控器，调到体育频道，冠军足球。当他们错过传球时，他咒骂电视。当他们得分时，他起身跳了一小段胜利之舞。比赛结束后，他告诉你他的喉咙干了，肚子在咕咕叫。他真的需要啤酒和一块好肉。如果可能的话，多加点洋葱圈，全熟的。但他也会满足于一些猪排。
So you get in the car and take him to this restaurant that he knows about and you don't. This new twist has you worried. It really does, but you have no idea what to do about it. Your command and control centers are down. You shift gears at the exit in a daze. He's right there beside you in the passenger seat tapping that gold ring pinky of his. At the next intersection, he rolls down his window, winks at you and yells at this chick who's thumbing a ride. "Hey baby, wanna play nanny goat and ride in the back?"
所以你上车带他去这家餐馆，他知道而你不知道。这个新的转折让你担心。确实如此，但你不知道该怎么办。你的指挥和控制中心瘫痪了。你在出口处恍惚地换挡。他就在你旁边的副驾驶座上，敲着他那戴着金戒指的小指。在下一个十字路口，他摇下窗户，向你眨眨眼，对那个正在搭便车的女孩大喊。“嘿宝贝，想玩山羊游戏，坐到后面来吗？”
Later the two of you pack in the steak and the chops and the onion rings till you're about to explode. And he enjoys every bite and laughs like a baby. And all that time you keep telling yourself, it's got to be a dream, a bizarre dream, yes, but definitely one that you'll snap out of any minute. On the way back, you ask him where to let him off, and he pretends not to hear you. But he looks despondent. So you wind up taking him back home with you. It's almost 3:00 AM. "I'm gonna hit the sack," you tell him. And he waves to you, stays in the beanbag chair staring at the fashion channel.
后来你们两个大吃牛排、猪排和洋葱圈，直到你要爆炸。他享受每一口，笑得像个孩子。在那段时间里，你一直告诉自己，这一定是个梦，一个奇怪的梦，是的，但绝对是你随时都会醒来的那种。回来的路上，你问他在哪里让他下车，他假装没听见你。但他看起来很沮丧。所以你最终把他带回家了。快凌晨3点了。“我要去睡觉了，”你告诉他。他向你挥挥手，待在懒人沙发上盯着时尚频道。
You wake up the next morning exhausted with a slight stomach ache. And there she is in the living room still dozing. By the time you've had your shower, she's up. She hugs you guiltily, and you're too embarrassed to say anything. Time goes by and you're still together. The sex just gets better and better. And she's not so young anymore, neither are you, and suddenly you find yourself talking about a baby.
第二天早上你醒来时精疲力竭，肚子有点痛。她还在客厅里打盹。等你洗完澡，她已经起来了。她内疚地拥抱你，你太尴尬了，什么也没说。时间流逝，你们还在一起。性生活变得越来越好。她不再那么年轻了，你也是，突然间你发现自己在谈论生孩子。
And at night, you and the fatso guy hit the town like you've never done in your life. He takes you to restaurants and bars you didn't even know existed. And you dance on tables together, break plates like there's no tomorrow. He's really nice, the fatso guy, a little crass, especially with women. Sometimes coming out with things that make you just want to die. But other than that, he's great fun to be with.
晚上，你和那个胖子像你生活中从未做过的那样去城里玩。他带你去一些你甚至不知道存在的餐馆和酒吧。你们一起在桌子上跳舞，摔盘子，仿佛没有明天。他真的很好，那个胖子，有点粗鲁，特别是对待女性的时候。有时说出的话让你只想死。但除此之外，和他在一起真的很有趣。
When you first met him, you didn't give a damn about football, but now you know every team. And whenever one of your favorites wins, you feel like you've made a wish and it's come true, which is a pretty exceptional feeling for someone like who hardly knows what he wants most of the time. And so it goes. Every night you fall asleep with him struggling to stay awake for the early scores on ESPN. And in the morning, there she is, the beautiful, forgiving woman that you love too. Till it hurts.
当你第一次见到他时，你根本不在乎足球，但现在你了解每一支球队。每当你的最爱之一获胜时，你感觉就像你许了一个愿望，它成真了，这对于一个大部分时间都不知道自己想要什么的人来说，是一种非常特别的感觉。事情就是这样。每天晚上你和他一起睡着，努力为ESPN的早期比分保持清醒。早上，她就在那里，你爱的那个美丽、宽容的女人。直到它受伤。
Matt Mallow, reading Etgar Keret's story, "Fatso." Keret is the author of a book of evocative, fable-like stories of every day life called The Bus Driver Who Wanted To Be God. His story was translated into English by Miriam Shlesinger.
马特·马洛伊，朗读埃特加·凯雷特的短篇小说《胖子》。凯雷特是一本名为《想当上帝的巴士司机》的充满唤起性、寓言式日常生活故事集的作者。他的故事由米里亚姆·施莱辛格（Miriam Shlesinger）翻译成英语。
[MUSIC  - "SHE'S GOT EVERYTHING" BY THE KINKS]
[音乐 - THE KINKS的"SHE'S GOT EVERYTHING"]
Act Four, this is the story of people trying to take the high road. They are enemies, political enemies living in each other's midst trying to get along. It takes place in a mostly conservative town of just 5,000 people in upstate New York. Blue Chevigny has the story.
第四幕，这是一个关于人们试图走高尚之路的故事。他们是敌人，生活在彼此中间的政治敌人，试图和睦相处。故事发生在纽约州北部一个拥有5000人口的保守小镇。蓝·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）报道。
Kathy and Joy can't quite recall the first time they talked to each other. But the one thing they're both very clear on is that their friendship started some time after they'd already seen each other dozens of times, protesting on opposite sides of Main Street, on opposite sides of an issue.
凯西（Kathy）和乔伊（Joy）不太记得他们第一次交谈是什么时候。但他们俩都很清楚的一点是，他们的友谊是在他们已经看到过对方几十次之后开始的，在主街的两边抗议，在议题的两边抗议。
It was probably some comment one of us made about the other one's sign or something along that line.
可能就是我们其中一个人对另一个人的标语之类的发表了一些评论。
But you don't usually hold signs. You usually held the flag and waved, so I don't know. It could have been about that the fact that people would often drive by and beep. Remember this? They'd drive by and beep. And they'd either wave at Joy and flip me the bird. Or they'd beep and they'd wave at me and flip Joy the bird simultaneously.
但你通常不举标语。你通常拿着旗帜挥舞，所以我不知道。可能是关于人们经常开车经过并按喇叭的事实。还记得吗？他们开车经过并按喇叭。他们要么向乔伊挥手，向我竖中指。或者他们按喇叭，向我挥手，同时向乔伊竖中指。
Kathy, an ordained minister in her late 40s with short salt and pepper hair, was protesting the war in Iraq every night at 7:00, standing with signs in the central square of her hometown with a dozen other people since the fall of 2002 before the war began. And across the street, from her window at work, Joy watched this night after night and got angrier and angrier. Joy's a blond woman in her early 30s who works at a stock photo company just down the street from the square.
凯西是一位40多岁、有着盐和胡椒色短发的受戒牧师，从2002年秋天战争开始前，她每天晚上7点都在抗议伊拉克战争，和另外十几个人一起站在家乡的中央广场拿着标语。而在街对面，从她工作的地方的窗户里，乔伊夜复一夜地看着这一切，越来越愤怒。乔伊是一位30出头的金发女性，在广场街下方的股票照片公司工作。
I had heard the group, Not In Our Name. I'd heard of them. And I thought well, not in my name are they going to stand out there and protest against my country and my president and whatnot. And so that's what inspired me.
我听说过那个组织，“不是以我们的名义”。我听说过他们。我想，嗯，他们绝对不能以我的名义站在那里，抗议我的国家和我的总统之类的。所以这就是激励我的原因。
So one day, she invited her father, who also supported the war, to come out and protest the protesters. She stood across the street from them, waved a big flag and smiled at passersby. She tried to go there every night, sometimes with one or two others, but often alone. Over time, it got more and more intense. Kathy, the anti-war one, started coming to the town square by herself at all hours of the day to collect for UNICEF Iraq as an act of solidarity with the Iraqi people and the United Nations, which had refused to support the war.
所以有一天，她邀请也支持战争的父亲出来抗议抗议者。她站在他们对面，挥舞着一面大旗，对路人微笑。她试图每天晚上都去那里，有时带着一两个其他人，但通常独自一人。随着时间的推移，情况变得越来越激烈。反战的凯西开始在一天中的任何时候独自来到城镇广场，为伊拉克联合国儿童基金会筹款，作为与伊拉克人民和拒绝支持战争的联合国团结一致的行动。
In response, Joy started coming to her spot, in the mornings before work as well as after, to counteract Kathy's near constant presence. And it was during one of those times, when they were both standing by themselves, that they struck up a friendship. This is Joy.
作为回应，乔伊开始在工作前后的早晨来到她的位置，以抵消凯西几乎持续的存在。正是在其中一次他们都独自站着的时候，他们建立起了友谊。这是乔伊。
She's come over and stood with me. She's even borrowed my flag one day. I have a big three by five flag on a pole.
她走过来和我站在一起。她甚至有一天借了我的旗帜。我有一面三乘五的大旗，插在杆子上。
What did you borrow the flag for?
你借旗帜干什么？
To burn.
烧掉。
Why did I borrow the flag? Because I really believed that it's important for the protesters to hold on to the flag.
我为什么要借旗帜？因为我真的相信抗议者保持旗帜很重要。
How did you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
It was fine with me. It's the flag, why not share it? It's a symbol of everything that we hold dear. And don't we want to share that with everybody?
对我来说没问题。那是国旗，为什么不分享呢？它是我们所珍视的一切的象征。我们难道不想和每个人分享吗？
They got to know each other better as the weeks went by. They found that they had a surprising number of things in common, not just the flag. They both had family members in the military who were in active duty in Iraq. And they would fill each other in on any news about them when they saw each other each day. Joy came to know Kathy's favorite lunch and coffee spots on Main Street. They had a similar sense of humor.
随着几周过去，他们彼此更加了解了。他们发现他们有惊人数量的共同点，不仅仅是旗帜。他们都有在伊拉克服现役的军事家属。他们每天见面时都会告诉对方关于他们的任何消息。乔伊开始了解凯西在主街上最喜欢的午餐和咖啡馆。他们有相似的幽默感。
But the thing that they both felt the most strongly was their pride. That in spite of their political differences, they were able to bridge the gap between them and make peace unlike the rest of the world.
但他们俩感觉最强烈的是他们的自豪感。尽管有政治分歧，他们还是能够弥合分歧，实现和平，不像世界上其他人那样。
I think that we have found a lot of common ground.
我认为我们找到了很多共同点。
I think that we're doing in this small town between us what I'd like to see our political leaders do more of.
我认为我们在这个小镇所做的，正是我希望看到我们的政治领导人多做一些的事。
Not that they didn't have their problems with each other. At one point our conversation, Joy, the pro-war one, listed off her current complaints about Kathy and the other anti-war protesters. They had taken over the village square, trampling and killing the grass and leaving their peace signs behind when they went for dinner or left overnight. Kathy sat quietly through this, though you could see her seething. Joy just seemed spurred on by that.
并不是说他们之间没有问题。在谈话的某一点上，支持战争的乔伊列出了她目前对凯西和其他反战抗议者的抱怨。他们占领了村广场，践踏和杀死了草坪，吃晚饭或过夜离开时留下了他们的和平标志。凯西静静地坐着，虽然你可以看到她在愤怒。乔伊似乎因为那样而被刺激了。
And I feel like it's disrespectful, really, to leave all that stuff there all the time people.
我觉得这很无礼，真的，总是把所有那些东西留在那里。
You seem a little mad the way you're talking.
你说话的样子看起来有点生气。
I'm not mad. Are you mad? You're mad?
我没有生气。你生气了吗？你生气了？
Sure.
当然。
You're mad at me?
你在生我的气吗？
I'm just mad in general.
我只是总体上很生气。
Kathy went on to say she was mad because she felt like President Bush had manipulated the public into believing they had something to fear from Iraq, that he had scared the American people.
凯西接着说，她生气是因为她觉得布什总统操纵了公众，让他们相信他们有什么需要从伊拉克那里担心的，他吓坏了美国人民。
So I think yes, President Bush, congratulations, you've done it. Thank [BLEEP] you.
所以我认为是的，布什总统，恭喜你，你做到了。谢了[消音]你。
Nice language for a minister.
作为一个牧师，语言很美妙。
Presbyterian Church by the way.
顺便说一句，长老会。
Are Presbyterian ministers allowed to swear?
长老会牧师被允许说脏话吗？
Are Christians allowed to kill?
基督徒被允许杀人吗？
Yes.
是的。
Ten commandments. Don't go to [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
十诫。不要去[听不清]。
Wait a second no. Because the ten commandments, if you look back at the original that it was written in, it's not that "Thou shalt not kill," it's "Thou shalt not murder."
等一下，不。因为十诫，如果你回头看它最初编写的原文，它不是“不可杀人”，而是“不可谋杀”。
Oh that's better.
哦，那更好。
Kathy widened her eyes and shook her head. Joy continued.
凯西睁大眼睛，摇了摇头。乔伊继续说。
I'll tell you what. I'll tell you what Kathy, I really believe there's nothing I could say that would ever convince you. There's nothing I could say that would ever convince you because I think you've made your mind that you're against the war but no matter what. No matter what anybody says. What if we find nuclear weapons there? What if we find--
我告诉你一件事。我告诉你一件事，凯西，我真的相信没有什么我能说的会让你信服。没有什么我能说的会让你信服，因为我觉得你已经下定决心，无论如何你都反对战争。不管别人怎么说。如果我们发现那里的核武器怎么办？如果我们发现——
Guess what, you're right. You're right about me.
猜猜看，你是对的。你是对的。
That wouldn't even matter to you would that they find nuclear weapons. That they find-- so really.
那对你来说甚至都不重要吗，他们发现了核武器？他们发现——所以真的。
Right.
对。
And then they simply stopped talking about it. Kathy calmly stated she needed to go to get back to the square and her collecting for UNICEF. They said no hard feelings, and laughed and hugged before she took off. That was in April. US troops were still fighting their way to Baghdad.
然后他们就停止谈论这件事了。凯西平静地说她需要回到广场，为联合国儿童基金会筹款。他们说没有记恨，笑着拥抱，然后她就离开了。那是在四月。美军仍在向巴格达战斗。
As I was leaving town that night, I thought it seemed so idyllic, these people in this little town who are able to be friends in spite of their staunchly opposed political views. Protesters from opposite camps don't usually sit down for coffee together at the end of the day. This seemed like a braver story, a story about putting yourself out on a limb more. In a small community, you can't ignore your opponent's in conflict, so you might as well walk across the street and shake their hand, introduce yourself, become friends.
那天晚上我离开城镇时，我想它看起来如此田园诗般，这些在小镇的人们，尽管有强烈反对的政治观点，却能够成为朋友。来自敌对阵营的抗议者通常不会在一天结束时坐在一起喝咖啡。这看起来是一个更勇敢的故事，一个关于让你自己身处险境的故事。在一个小社区里，你不能忽视对手的冲突，所以你还不如走过街去握住他们的手，介绍自己，成为朋友。
A couple of weeks after I talked to them, I called Kathy to check in and her husband answered the phone. Apparently there had been some developments since my last visit. Kathy and Joy's ideal-seeming friendship wasn't working so ideally anymore. I drove back up there, but this time Kathy and Joy asked to be interviewed separately.
我和他们谈过几周后，我打电话给凯西询问情况，她丈夫接了电话。显然，自从我上次访问以来，有一些事态发展。凯西和乔伊看起来理想的友谊不再那么理想了。我开车回到那里，但这次凯西和乔伊要求分开接受采访。
Remember how Joy was upset that the anti-war protesters had been trampling the grass in the town square? Well she and a few others went to the town board and requested formally that it be reseeded. The newly seeded area was cordoned off with yellow police tape that said "Crime Scene" on it. The peace protesters now had to stand outside of that area.
还记得乔伊因为反战抗议者践踏了城镇广场的草坪而感到不安吗？她和其他几个人去镇委员会正式要求重新播种。新播种的区域被黄色的警察胶带封锁，上面写着“犯罪现场”。和平抗议者现在必须站在那个区域之外。
Then one night, just before President Bush declared an end to active combat in Iraq, Kathy and Joy had a run-in. Kathy was with four or five other peace viligers. Joy was with her father, Walter. And it was his sign about UNICEF that sent Kathy over the edge. By then she'd spent all winter, hundreds of hours, on the square collecting for UNICEF. She'd averaged $9 an hour, a total of just under $2,000.
然后有一天晚上，就在布什总统宣布结束在伊拉克的活跃战斗之前，凯西和乔伊发生了冲突。凯西和其他四五个和平守夜者在一起。乔伊和她的父亲沃尔特在一起。正是他关于联合国儿童基金会的标语让凯西失去了理智。到那时，她已经在广场上花了整个冬天，数百个小时，为联合国儿童基金会筹款。她平均每小时筹到9美元，总额略低于2000美元。
They held up a sign that said, "UNICEF is a bad investment." I said "Oh Walter, come on. That's not very nice." And I turned to the adults with me and said, "I'm really angry. You're going to have to help me with this. I'm really, really angry because this feels like a personal jab at what I'm doing and I don't know what I'm going to do in response." The only advice I got was from Azim who said "follow your conscience, Kathy."
他们举着一个标语，上面写着，“联合国儿童基金会是一个糟糕的投资。”我说“哦沃尔特，得了吧。这不太好。”我转向和我一起的成年人说，“我真的很生气。你们得帮我。我真的很生气，因为这感觉像是在针对我所做的事情进行人身攻击，我不知道我该怎么回应。”我得到的唯一建议来自阿齐姆，他说“听从你的良心，凯西。”
I could see her jaw muscles set and her facial composure become rigid.
我可以看到她的下颚肌肉收紧，面部表情变得僵硬。
This is Azim, Kathy's friend and fellow vigiler.
这是阿齐姆，凯西的朋友和守夜同伴。
And then she half turned to me and said, "Talk me out of what I'm about to do." And I thought, oh my god, she's going to go over and assault them or start screaming or something. Don't do that Kathy. But my response, "Kathy, you're a big girl and you can do whatever you feel you need to do."
然后她半转过身对我说，“阻止我去做我正要做的事。”我想，天哪，她要冲过去袭击他们，或者开始尖叫什么的。别那样做，凯西。但我的回答是，“凯西，你是个大姑娘，你可以做任何你觉得需要做的事。”
The only thing that I double checked on was, "Kathy do you think that the grass seed has germinated yet?" The answer was-- my conscious said no. And I crossed the yellow ribbon and stood there, just glaring at Walter and Joy.
我唯一检查的事情是，“凯西，你觉得草种发芽了吗？”答案是——我的良心说没有。于是我穿过黄色丝带，站在那里，只是怒视着沃尔特和乔伊。
She was standing in the middle of the newly seeded grass. Her fellow vigilers looked away. Joy watched from across the street.
她站在新播种的草丛中间。她的守夜同伴看向别处。乔伊从街对面看着。
I was just so shocked that she did it. It was like, if she was mad at me or my dad, that was kind of-- why stand on the grass? I mean that like an attack on the whole village if you will. That was a statement to the whole village. It wasn't like it was to us.
我只是非常震惊她竟然这么做了。好像，如果她对我和我爸生气，那有点——为什么要站在草坪上？我的意思是这像是对整个村庄的攻击。那是对整个村庄的声明。这不像是针对我们。
Did she associate you with the grass being reseeded?
她是否把你和重新播种的草联系在一起？
Well I did ask to have the grass reseed. But a lot of people in the village had been asking the board to have the grass reseeded. Within a half hour, a police car pulled up. It was a young officer, someone who used to mow Kathy's lawn. He told her she would have to step off the grass or she'd be arrested. Soon backup arrived. Facing two officers, Kathy made a decision to be arrested. She was driven to the town police station, charged with disorderly conduct, given a court date and sent on her way. Here's Joy again.
嗯，我确实要求重新播种草。但村里很多人都一直在要求委员会重新播种草。半小时内，一辆警车停了下来。那是一位年轻的警官，以前给凯西修剪草坪的人。他告诉她必须离开草坪，否则她会被逮捕。很快增援部队到达。面对两名警官，凯西决定被逮捕。她被开车带到镇警察局，被指控行为不检，给了出庭日期，然后被送走了。这是乔伊。
She took it very, very personally instead of that it was directed-- the sign was regarding UNICEF. She felt like it was personal. At least that's what I've read in the paper.
她把它看得非常个人化，而不是——那个标语是关于联合国儿童基金会的。她觉得这是针对个人的。至少我在报纸上是这样读到的。
Since that night, Joy and Kathy haven't spoken. At her court date, Kathy's charge was reduced to six months probation. And since the incident, both women have avoided the town square. Joy's never gone back to wave her flag, and Kathy's doing most of her protesting and collecting elsewhere. Joy has seen her a few times from her car.
那天晚上以后，乔伊和凯西就没再说话。在她的出庭日期，凯西的指控被减为六个月缓刑。自该事件以来，两名女性都避开了城镇广场。乔伊再也没去挥舞她的旗帜，凯西也把大部分抗议和筹款活动转移到了别处。乔伊从她的车里见过她几次。
I've to catch her eye a couple times, and she sees me coming and looks the other way.
我有几次捕捉到她的目光，她看到我过来就看向别处。
What if you two ran into each other in the supermarket? What do you think would happen?
如果你们两个在超市偶遇呢？你觉得会发生什么？
I don't know. I mean I would be like, "Hi Kathy. How are you doing?" And just talk to her. I don't know what her reaction is. I wouldn't even know what her reaction might be.
我不知道。我的意思是我会说，“嗨凯西。你好吗？”然后和她说话。我不知道她的反应是什么。我甚至不知道她的反应可能会是什么。
I asked Kathy what she thinks will happen when they meet.
我问凯西，当他们见面时她认为会发生什么。
I picture that she would be the bigger of the two of us and would initiate reconciliation. I do.
我设想她会成为我们两个中更宽宏大量的一个，并主动发起和解。我是这么想的。
So you're not mad at her.
所以你不生她的气。
I won't say that.
我不会那样说。
But you would accept a gesture of reconciliation? You would reconcile?
但你会接受和解的姿态吗？你会和解吗？
I don't know. I don't know. I'm still angry. I don't think it's rational. It's hard to live up to. It's hard to live up to what I wish. It's struggling to live up with the failure in myself and in the world. Oh yeah, there's a big contradiction here. I was holding a sign that said "Imagine Dialogue." And I realized there are some people I don't want to dialogue with.
我不知道。我不知道。我还是很生气。我不认为这是理性的。很难做到。很难实现我的愿望。在挣扎着面对自己和世界中的失败。哦是的，这里有一个巨大的矛盾。我拿着一个写着“想象对话”的标语。我意识到有些我不想要对话的人。
I reminded Kathy what she said to me a month before about our political leaders and how she'd like to see them act more like her and Joy. Now that she and Joy weren't talking, she said she was appreciating the many advantages of not being world leaders.
我提醒凯西一个月前她对我们的政治领导人说的话，以及她如何希望看到他们表现得更像她和乔伊。现在她和乔伊不说话了，她说她开始欣赏不做世界领导人的许多好处。
I think sometimes you need to pull away. Joy and I have the luxury of time to do that. The entire fate of the universe isn't resting on our shoulders so we have time to pull away so that we can come back and try again.
我认为有时你需要退缩。乔伊和我拥有那样做的时间奢侈。宇宙的整个命运并不取决于我们的肩膀，所以我们有时间退缩，这样我们可以回来再试一次。
On way out of town, I interviewed some women in a local cafe. They were opposed to the war, and thought the vigils were a good thing. They told me, though, that I had stumbled into the cafe where I would find all the liberals. That if I wanted to find people who were in favor of the war, I should go right next door to the diner where the clientele was all right wing. They said the restaurants clearly divided up along political lines.
在离开小镇的路上，我在一家当地咖啡馆采访了一些女性。她们反对战争，认为守夜活动是件好事。然而，她们告诉我，我误打误撞进了咖啡馆，在那里我会找到所有的自由派。如果我想找到支持战争的人，我就应该直接去隔壁的餐馆，那里的客户都是右翼。她们说餐馆明显沿着政治路线划分。
I went next door and the tables were populated with older couples. The manager asked if she could help me with something. I asked her if would be OK to talk with some customers for a radio story. She asked what the topic was, and I told her it was about the protests up the street and I was looking for people's opinions. Her eyes literally narrowed. She said, "I have no comment, and I'd rather you not bother my customers during their lunch." Then she watched me until I was out the door.
我去了隔壁，餐桌上坐着年长的夫妇。经理问她是否能帮我什么。我问她是否可以和一些客户谈谈广播故事。她问主题是什么，我告诉她是关于街上的抗议活动，我在寻找人们的意见。她的眼睛真的眯了起来。她说，“我无可奉告，而且我宁愿你不要在我客户午餐时打扰他们。”然后她一直看着我，直到我走出门口。
And of course, this is the way it goes. Most people don't want a fight. Most people don't want to argue politics. And so the liberals stick with the liberals, and the conservatives stick with the conservatives. And who's got the energy for a constant meeting of the minds? What's more surprising than the fact that Kathy and Joy's friendship seems to have ended is that it ever happened in the first place.
当然，事情就是这样。大多数人不想吵架。大多数人不想争论政治。所以自由派和自由派待在一起，保守派和保守派待在一起。谁有精力去进行持续的思想碰撞呢？比凯西和乔伊的友谊似乎已经结束更令人惊讶的是，它竟然在一开始就发生了。
Blue Chevigny in New York City.
蓝·切维尼，在纽约市。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org where you know you can download audio of our show at audible.com/thisamericanlife where they have public radio programs, best selling books, even The New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Pubic Radio International.
我们的网站，www.thisamericanlife.org，你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频，在那里他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在audible.com。 《美国生活》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who has just one question for you.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他只有一个问题要问你。
Hey baby, wanna play nanny goat and ride in the back?
嘿宝贝，想玩山羊游戏，坐到后面来吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。